as a new yorker you're always defending
new york at its worst
right when people attack it for being
filthy for being crowd or for people
being rude
all my life i've said you just don't get
it you don't understand or
that's part of what makes new yorkers
tough we can survive it you can't
and only in the last year with covid and
what mayor de blasio
governor cuomo have done have i come
around to
i was wrong and these people were right
all right i'm dave rubin and we're doing
something a little different today i am
live in studio with my guest who is just
outside
i have not seen him yet but i have been
told that he is wearing a tiny
mask due to proper
safety protocols related to kovid
here he is michael now
michael malus welcome to the ruby report
good to see you it's good to see you
again feel your face yes feel like
please
this is very uh exciting i didn't know
what you were going to be doing today
um you told me you had something in
store for me
it's good to see you i wish i could say
the same
but i can't honestly first off i love
the suit the color is great the shirt's
nice tai the the whole shebang where did
you get this
little face get up i know you're you've
been kova's very serious and you've been
very serious about it
you didn't even praise the shoes no your
shoes the whole thing is these are sea
leather
from the 70s is that right you could
when you could get seal leather that's
right
yeah that's very impressive nowadays no
no no you can't get it you have to get
on the black market now
um i have a feeling we're going to do
the entire interview this way
well of course this is we can't joke
around no no this is serious
yeah i don't want to kill your grandma
no thank you they're both dead
well i don't want to kill her again
already yeah yeah
so you've been walking around like this
i assume wandering through la with
with your i have a little cane and one
of those
um uh dogs yeah and i fit right in
now are you here this is what i want to
ask you one of the things that i've seen
yes when i'm walking around
l.a i'm from new york as you know yeah
people you're a brooklyn guy
i've lived there all my life and now i'm
at the point where i'm
joined the chorus of well let me take a
step back as a new yorker
you're always defending new york at its
worst right when people
attack it for being filthy for being
proud or for people being rude
all my life i've said you just don't
get it you don't understand or that's
part of what makes new yorkers tough
we can survive it you can't and only in
the last year
with kovid and what mayor de blasio
governor cuomo have done
have i come around to i was wrong
and these people were right what they've
done to new york city the crown jewel of
america
you know one of the great cities of all
time is unforgivable and unacceptable
and there's no possibility in my opinion
of things getting better and i'm curious
you think they can never
in the medium term yeah in the medium
term there's no mechanism for it to get
better
if i'm a young person and i want to make
a store that sells like artisanal socks
cheeses i'm a young restaurateur i want
to open up a
cool new restaurant why would i go into
new york city now
where every single regulation is against
me
where i'm being told constantly maybe
not explicitly but implicitly
we don't want you here you're not
welcome new york is not open for
business
and we're just going to shut you down at
the drop of a hat
and i feel as if la is
kind of similar in that vein that it's
going to get worse
because there's no mechanism for it to
get better i'm curious to hear your
thoughts on that
yeah well as you know i think la is an
absolute disaster and i've only been to
new york
once since i can't believe i'm talking
to you in this thing this is really
you look good this is actually the best
you've looked honestly of course
you have to see my hideous face um
no i've only been to new york once since
this whole thing happened i was in
midtown manhattan because i was doing
the gut fell show at fox
and it was scary it felt like i am
legend there were there were no business
people out
there are only people out walking alone
with masks and hats
and it was kind of cold so jackets and
everyone looks kind of shady and there's
cops and a lot of barricades and all
that stuff and it's like
how does this ever come back and here i
mean you know the main the main i don't
want to say exactly where we are but the
main drag here
still a ton of boarded up stuff there's
what what mom and pop shop
forget young people you said young
people what person that had their
business closed in the last year that is
experienced maybe even has a little
money could be like yeah let's do it
again let's do it again so newsome can
shut us down
next month when we have the climate
lockdowns or coveyed too or
give me something better than that uh
the only possibility of things getting
better i tweeted this
uh this week if caitlyn jenner runs on a
campaign
of hitting and running governor newsom i
think she would get elected in a
landslide but here's what what people
don't appreciate
they thought one day detroit could never
go anywhere
not only was detroit motor city the home
of the automobile industry
the music coming out of detroit still
resonates decades later
still legendary decades later now
detroit is
a bombed out shelter of a hole in the
ground of what it used to be
hollywood in my view is running on fumes
on inertia
of the golden age you know you go to la
every pretty girl
every hunk from their hometown cup as
you did
comes to los angeles to make their name
to make their mark
and now the movie industry doesn't have
that cachet
it's not like the place you have to be
anymore because thanks to the internet
there's so many more venues for young
filmmakers
especially internationally to on a small
budget
create and innovate something amazing
parasite you know which came out of
south korea yeah what won the academy
award there's such a hunger
uh for and it's not even a right or left
wing thing
there's such a hunger for new voices new
creativity
but hollywood and these media
establishment entities
are so corporate that whether you're
reading a comic book
or you're reading about the middle ages
or you're reading about a documentary
the messaging the culture the punch
lines are
all going to be the same so why would
you come here
where you could hang up your shingle and
be a filmmaker and be
as opposed to hollywood and you're going
to have some have an edge that way
we're going out to dinner after this are
you going to be dressed like this well
sure
how are you going to eat how you can eat
well i mean i'm on a cut i'm going to be
doing an underwear ad so are you shocked
so
so look you live in brooklyn i was born
in brooklyn
and i've only lived in new york and now
la
you're a new yorker a true new yorker
are you shocked how quickly
everybody folded and that still now
people i assume in brooklyn are
wandering around with masks outdoors and
the
dingbats that i'm walking by over here
are you doing the same to tell you what
level of new yorker i am in the audience
yeah i don't know how to drive so i'm
gonna have to learn how to drive
i am
this is what i'm shocked about i am
shocked
to what level americans who have prided
themselves
on their sense of defiance who in 2016
had an opportunity to vote for someone
in large part to just give the finger to
the corporate press
how solidly they folded in the wake
of these lockdowns and were subservient
and what's even worse
and this is where it gets from the point
of okay maybe you're a little bit weak
maybe a little bit fearful i can wrap my
head around that i'm not a particular
tough guy
but when you see things like in canada
there was a woman who tweeted i'm sure
you saw this i'm sure many people saw
this
there was a i think was ontario where
the message went out that
your children should be quarantined
in a room in your home for two weeks and
when i went after this people
couldn't even believe it they assumed i
meant just being locked in your house
with your family which
isn't ideal but it's hardly a nightmare
right and the woman was tweeting that
it was heartbreaking for her to hear her
child yeah banging on the door saying
mommy i'm lonely or mommy
whatever it was i'm scared and i'm
thinking to myself i don't care what
your political persuasion is
if you or i or virtually anyone
listening to this if you're
like at a mall and there's a child who's
lost and scared
you if they're not ugly you stop and
you're like what's wrong
how can i help you let's find your mom
and dad let's keep you
entertained and calm until mom and dad
get here this is just
humanity 101 and i say this as someone
without any facial features
so to have people not only do this but
to
post about it on social media and not
just you would think that
i could even wrap my head around being
like oh yeah i'm totally doing this and
at home being like i don't care what the
what the news says exactly i'm not gonna
not hug my children
exactly so i'm an uncle now i've got two
nephews i absolutely adore them
and if someone says you know lock them
in a room for two weeks
we're not having a conversation that is
you declaring war in my family
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell